congratulations
cannot believe it I really can't believe
it there are a lot of like cool things
that you think about in your lifetime
this one this one's like top of the Heap
by the way I have the old Forbes 50 over
50. I have them very first I have the
first one I was like sent Marshall who
let me I was learning about all these
women and I thought how do I not know
them I was just fascinated by it and
honored it's an amazing list and I think
it has an amazing message and that is
long Runway
longer than we thought do you remember I
do
I remember when we were both at NBC
and I just remember where we were in our
careers and how we were kind of hobbling
on and wondering like was the end 15
years ago 20 years ago could that have
been the end of our careers and look at
us sitting here I mean it's so my career
actually ended
yeah and then you were
you I heard the saying it gets greater
later
it gets greater later and it does it
gets greater in every single aspect of
life and don't you wish we knew that I
wish younger women would hold on to that
you know what's weird I was thinking if
someone told me hey I'm gonna guess what
when you when you're in you're like your
mid-50s you're going to be a mom of two
and you'll be hosting the Today Show but
you're gonna have to wait till your mid
50s I would have said like are you
kidding me and now that I'm sitting in
the middle of this I can't believe how
blessed I feel how just how I can't
believe this stage in my life feels like
this did you ever imagine your career
after 50 no oh no way I didn't either
well I think it was because we kind of
watched people's careers come and go
didn't we it was like you knew that
there was there was always the old guy
anchor and the young girl anchor and you
never kind of it was never us it was
never ever us I think it was kind of
funny like you watched you watched this
and you thought that was the norm and
then one day you turned 45 and you were
here and you turned 50 and you're here
then you looked across the street and
you saw Katie Couric you saw Merida
Fiera yeah you see Oprah you see Gail
King you see Robin Roberts you see
Savannah you see Savannah two women yes
and I think you once you can't see you
can't be it unless you see it you're
like oh we we can do that like that's a
possibility and yet for you it's
multifaceted like what would you
consider your greatest accomplishment
over the age of 50. my greatest
accomplishment over the age of 50 uh is
having Haley and Hope
without question who would have uh
imagined I didn't see it coming I
literally watched it live when you broke
the news and I thought are you kidding
me well oh my gosh well you know what
it's like when you have a dream that you
cannot fulfill
because you know it's too late so you
don't say it out loud because if you say
it
then you're presenting something you're
never going to have and I remember
thinking
whisper it to yourself whatever your
secret is say it out loud even if it's
just to yourself in the bathroom mirror
or tell your best friend or tell some
someone because once you say something
that you desire you put it in the
universe it comes somehow it comes to
you and I remember saying it out loud I
A friend of mine and I were walking down
the street and I remember and she said
well we never wanted kids
and mid-sentence I said well actually I
did
and she said well you never said that
and I said
well because I'm 50 so I don't want to
say it but I've always wanted them I've
always kind of dreamed about it and lo
and behold the minute I said it kind of
out into the universe
I started thinking like why not me
why not me why why not me and everywhere
I looked I saw a woman who was around my
age with a child I looked I was like
Sandra Bullock
like Googling her how old is Sandra
Bullock boom I was like oh my God it's
possible and I think then I realized it
I could I could have that I think it
really actually makes the message of 50
over 50 so much more robust you can
achieve massive success over 50. we have
women over 60 over 70 over 80 over 90.
wow reaching their highest impact really
killing it and what you're telling us is
that you can find happiness too Mika as
I sit here today across from you at 58.
I know I have never ever in my life been
this happy never
this decade of my life is by far the
best decade I have ever had and I would
never have imagined that
to have been a possibility and I think
there's something about realizing like
numbers or numbers
and love is love and you can make things
happen in your life if you want it if
you really want it it's not an
impossibility and it works that way in
your personal life and it works that way
in your professional life I think if you
are someone who's always asking what are
the odds
I have a feeling you might have a
difficult time climbing your Mountain
because if anyone had told me the odds
of having kids after 50 or the odds of
hosting the Today Show in my late 50s
I'm sure someone with a calculator would
have said oh it's you know 7 million to
one good luck with that idea but I think
if we don't know it we just go for it
who's going to tell us you know no did
you ever have a moment in your life
before the age of 50 where you almost
gave up I'm a worker
I'm a grinder I'm not the most talented
I'm not top of my class I'm not that
person we are not those people we're
just not but we're not but I'm a grinder
and the one thing I think I do really
well is I get up I get up you just like
I'll fall a million times but I think
the getting up piece is it because there
are people way more talented than me
than you who sometimes you fall too many
times and you don't get up because you
say it's not meant to be it must not be
meant to be but I think I used to play
basketball in high school
and I believed with 15 seconds on the
clock down Five Points we could do it I
calculate I was like you know what's
going to happen I'm getting the ball I'm
going to shoot I'm get fouled I'm gonna
hit the two I'm gonna go for that foul
shot I'm gonna miss it but get the
rebound that's four get like I believed
to the end it was possible and I think
that's what you have to have it's like
that fight like I believe to the last
second I it it might happen and I think
that's it you just have to fight until
you're out of gas I can't wait to ask
you this next question what do you say
to younger women in their 20s and 30s
who are
um like I was rushing trying so hard to
like check off all the boxes like
constantly in a rush because you think
you've got this clock ticking you know I
I had my career riding sidecar my whole
life
and everything fell to that I said my
career goes first boyfriend backseat
career sidecar that's how I rolled
and I did it because that's what was in
me at the time and I think the only
thing I feel about that is sometimes you
you just have to do what's in you if you
feel like pushing your career into your
40s do it
you know I don't have any regrets
because I did that and I ended up being
able to have my family too but I think
don't rush don't rush it you know I I
feel like in every Market I ever worked
I looked for someone who was better I
tried to get as good as I could get and
then I would move on but I didn't I
didn't get to the network until I think
I was in my I think I was late 30s or
40s and then I was running around with
Dateline for years overseas and people
said oh you don't work anymore at NBC I
was like yeah I'm just always on a plane
but that was what I did so I think all
the best things in life happened in my
50s and we took all the lessons we
learned and kind of Applied them I I
think just slow it down and it's hard to
say don't worry but don't worry
yes I remember I actually called Robin
Roberts and I said oh my God can you
believe I'm 50 whatever I was 52 and I'm
and I have a baby and she said you know
what that baby is Hoda and I said what
she said that baby's right on time and I
thought everything's right on time
your job for you is right on time my job
for me right now is right on time we're
right on time you know we're not on
anyone else's timetable and so I think
that's what you have to remember
whenever your stuff happens some people
get all their blessings in their 20s
some people get them in their 30s some
people get them in their 40s some people
give them their 50s or 60s or 70s or
like you said 80s and 90s it's a long
Runway it comes yeah two beautiful girls
hope and Haley biggest struggles and
rewards just from from moms who are
thinking of a similar path having kids
in their 50s I love having children in
my 50s I love having a three and a
five-year-old I love it
um when I go to the gym to work out I
make sure I lift 40 pounds or more
because I want to hoist Haley my
trainer's like what do you want to lift
I said I want to lift 40 pounds Haley
and when she turned when she weighs 50
pounds I want to lift 50. like I just
feel like there is time for every thing
in your life and I feel like having kids
in your 50s I mean I'm so much calmer
than I was I'm so much smarter I'm
living in the moment I'm marveling at
them a friend of mine I said what's the
key to raising great great kids because
she has grown children and she said oh I
know it's four words and I said well
what is what are they
she said listen and love love love and I
was like hmm it's so simple some of it
so now I Marvel at them I listen to them
I don't talk over them I try really hard
and I feel like I have patience now but
I didn't have them and I also have a
schedule that allows me to see them more
because I'm I'm done in the morning so I
think having kids in your 50s is pretty
spectacular I don't know what it's like
to have kids in my 30s or my 40s I don't
know what that feels like but I do know
that this is the right time for me I
feel like I'm raising good girls who are
um givers and kind and and that's kind
of all I want my girls at Sea I was 28
and 30 and I was so I was on overnights
mornings whatever I was doing at MSNBC
that stuff yes home page yes oh yeah CBS
and then oh my gosh
taking the time to listen I look back
and I'm like it was it was everything
was so rush rush yeah and if I could do
it again I would do it in my 50s because
I feel like I have so much more to offer
and I can be still yes and love it yes
each day I actually write my journal
every morning like dear God like thank
you for this precious day a day that
will never ever be repeated allow me to
find the love and the lessons that are
here because I keep reminding myself
like this isn't just a Thursday this
this day we will not see again today my
daughter hope went to school for the
first day and I got to take her and pick
her up it was a half an hour day 11 30
to 12. but it was awesome and I watched
her with that backpack and I was like oh
my God like I get this moment I get to
like live in this moment This Moment's
not repeating so I think it's like it's
like Savor and linger that's what I'm
trying to do Savor and linger does Hoda
have more plans
um what do you think when you look at
this I do
um I dream of
um being a being a part of a summer camp
for girls that teaches them just
empowerment at that young age and in
that same area like I see a big women's
empowerment kind of uh facility where
women who otherwise couldn't go to some
of these places get to go and realize if
they want to change career or if they're
having relationship issues or whatever
their thing is that it's a place they
can go and fill up it's like long
weekends so I picture like summer camp
in the Summer Long weekends
um throughout the year and just a place
where women and girls Thrive at a place
they remember and a place they take with
them like it fills them up when they
when they go so that can I help yes you
can okay you're gonna be speaker number
one I'm so in I want to do more thank
you
[Music]